ich will etwas neues machen
ich werde anfangen im internet nach
einem job zu suchen
mal schauen was es gibt
ich will etwas neues machen ich werde
anfangen im internet nach einem job zu
suchen
mal schauen was es gibt
wow dieses inserat ist sehr interessant
hob er im ausland ich habe das noch nie
gemacht aber ich denke es ist ein gutes
angebot
wow dieses inserat ist sehr interessant
ob er im ausland ich habe das noch nie
gemacht aber ich denke es ist ein gutes
angebot
und ich werde die möglichkeit haben ein
anderes land kennen zu lernen und
gleichzeitig zu arbeiten
ich werde mich bewerben
und ich werde die möglichkeit haben ein
anderes land kennen zu lernen und
gleichzeitig zu arbeiten
ich werde mich bewerben
[Musik]
hallo
guten tag mein name ist carla lässt kann
ich bitte mit lisa gomez sprechen
guten tag mein name ist paula hernández
kann ich später mit melissa gomez
sprechen
sie sprechen schon mit ihr
ich bin mehliser gomez
sie sprechen schon mit ihr ich bin
melissa ganz prima wir rufen sie an weil
sie sich um eine stelle als opel
beworben habe
prima wie lüften sie an weil sie sich um
eine stelle als ob erworben haben
ja genau ich habe ihr inserat im
internet gefunden
wir haben uns in den lebenslauf
angesehen und fanden ihn interessant und
wir möchten sie morgen zu einem
vorstellungsgespräch in unserer agentur
einladen
wir haben uns in den lebenslauf
angesehen und fanden ihn interessant und
wir möchten sie morgen zu einem
vorstellungsgespräch in unsere agentur
einladen
geht es ihnen morgen um 10 uhr geht es
ihnen morgen um 10 uhr 10 uhr passt
perfekt können sie mir ihre adresse
geben
10 uhr passt perfekt können sie mir ihre
adresse geben
die adresse ist bahnhofstraße 24
wir erwarten sie morgen um 10 uhr in
unserem video
die adresse es bahnhofstraße 24
wir erwarten sie morgen um 10 uhr in
unserem büro
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen tag und
wir freuen uns sie morgen persönlich
kennenzulernen
ich wünsche ihnen einen schönen tag und
wir freuen uns sie morgen persönlich
kennenzulernen
vielen dank ich freue mich auch bis
morgen
guten morgen ich habe um 8 uhr ein
vorstellungsgespräch mit frau maria
serrano guten morgen ich habe um 8 uhr
ein vorstellungsgespräch mit frau maria
serrano
wie ist ihr name wie ist ihr name
melissa gomez vielen dank
ich gebe für aus iran gleich bescheid
dass sie da sind
einen moment bitte vielen dank
ich gebe für aus der warnung gleich
bescheid dass sie da sind
einen moment bitte guten tag frau selena
gomez ist her
guten tag frau aus der ladung frau gomez
ist hier ja bitte lassen sie sie herein
ja bitte lassen sie sie herein
guten morgen frau gomez willkommen mein
name ist maria serrano und ich bin
zuständig für die rekrutierung der ubs
guten morgen frau gomez willkommen mein
name ist maria serrano und ich bin
zuständig für die rekrutierung der ubs
guten morgen frau serrano
ich werde ihnen von der arbeit und den
lohnbedingungen erzählen damit sie einen
ersten eindruck bekommen können
ich werde ihnen von der arbeit und den
lohnbedingungen erzählen damit sie einen
ersten eindruck bekommen können
ja sehr gerne
sie bewerben sich um eine stelle als ob
er in einem anderen land der lohn
variiert je nach familie aber sie
bekommen zwischen 700 und 800 schweizer
franken
sie bewerben sich um eine stelle als ob
er in einem anderen land der lohn
variiert je nach familie aber sie
bekommen zwischen 700 und 800 schweizer
franken
sie müssen weder für das essen noch für
die unterkunft geld ausgeben da sie im
selben haus wohnen werden indem sie sich
um das kind kümmern werden
sie müssen weder für das essen noch für
die unterkunft geld ausgeben da sie im
selben haus wohnen werden indem sie sich
um das kind kümmern werden
wow das klingt super
sagen sie mir leben sie bei ihren eltern
oder einem verwandten
ich lebe weder bei meinen eltern noch
bei einem verwandten
ich lebe allein
ich lebe weder bei meinen eltern noch
bei einem verwandten
ich lebe allein
sehr gut und sagen sie mir sind sie
verheiratet oder ledig
ich bin nicht nur ledig sondern auch
single ich habe derzeit keinen freund
sprechen sie deutsch oder englisch
ich spreche sowohl deutsch als auch
englisch da ich die möglichkeit hatte an
eine zweisprachige schule zu gehen
wo die zweite sprache deutsch war ich
habe englisch gelernt als ich drei jahre
lang in den vereinigten staaten lebt
ich spreche sowohl deutsch als auch
englisch da ich die möglichkeit hatte an
eine zweisprachige schule zu gehen
wo die zweite sprache deutsch war ich
habe englisch gelernt als ich drei jahre
lang in den vereinigten staaten lebte
haben sie sich schon einmal in einer
kindertagesstätte oder schule gearbeitet
ich habe noch nie in einer
aber ich kann ihnen versichern
dass ich schnell lerne und ich freue
mich auf diese arbeit
ich habe noch nie in einer
kindertagesstätte oder schule gearbeitet
aber ich kann ihnen versichern
dass ich schnell lerne und ich freue
mich auf diese arbeit halten sie sich
selbst für malerisch oder spielerisch
begabt
halten sie sich selbst für malerisch
oder spielerisch begabt
zwar male ich nicht sehr gut aber ich
habe viel spaß dabei ich liebe es zu
spielen und bin sehr kreativ
zwar male ich nicht sehr gut aber ich
habe viel spaß dabei ich liebe es zu
spielen und bin sehr kreativ
sind sie ein geduldiger mensch
ich bin sehr geduldig und
verständnisvoll
bin sehr geduldig und verständnisvoll
kennen sie gut kochen
ich kann sowohl gut kochen als auch
leckere desserts zubereiten kochen ist
meine leidenschaft
ich kann sowohl gut kochen als auch
leckere desserts zu bereiten
kochen ist meine leidenschaft
sehen sie sich lieber einen
animationsfilm an
einerseits mag ich animationsfilm weil
sie meistens sehr lustig sind
andererseits faszinieren mich
actionfilme
weil sie immer sehr spannend sind mit
kindern schaue ich natürlich immer
animationsfilm
einerseits mag ich animationsfilm weil
sie meistens sehr lustig sind
andererseits faszinieren mich
actionfilme
weil sie immer sehr spannend sind mit
kindern schaue ich natürlich immer
animationsfilm
haben sie schon einmal eine ähnliche
arbeit gemacht
ich habe noch nie mit kindern gearbeitet
da meine schwester zwei kinder hat weiß
ich wie man mit kindern umgeht
ich habe noch nie mit kindern gearbeitet
da meine schwester zwei kinder hat weiß
ich wie man mit kindern umgeht
was wissen sie über unsere agentur
ich kenne ihr unternehmen sowie andere
unternehmen die sich ebenfalls der
personalrekrutierung für opas widmen
sie waren das erste unternehmen in
unserem land das frauen in andere länder
entsandt hat um als ob er zu arbeiten
und sie gehören heute weltweit zu den
besten auf diesem gebiet
ich kenne ihr unternehmen sowie andere
unternehmen die sich ebenfalls der
personalrekrutierung für opas widmen
sie waren das erste unternehmen in
unserem land
dass frauen in andere länder entsandt
hat um als ob er zu arbeiten und sie
gehören heute weltweit zu den besten auf
diesem gebiet
a ich sehe sie haben sich sehr gut
informiert
ich sehe sie haben sich sehr gut
was waren die hauptfunktionen die sie in
ihrer früheren tätigkeit ausgeübt haben
in meinem vorherigen job war ich sowohl
verkäuferin als auch managerin eines
kleider geschäfts
in meinem vorherigen job war ich sowohl
verkäuferin als auch managerin eines
kleidergeschäft
ein guter kundenservice ist in jedem
unternehmen wichtig
wie reagieren sie auf druck
[Musik]
kein problem mit druck und stress in
meinem vorherigen job habe ich gelernt
mit stress umzugehen wenn viele kunden
da waren und ich allein war
habe kein problem mit druck und stress
in meinem vorherigen job habe ich
gelernt mit stress umzugehen wenn viele
kunden da waren und ich allein war
das klingt sehr gut
haben sie erfahrung in der babypflege
ja wie gesagt meine schwester hat zwei
kinder
und ich habe ihr manchmal mit den babys
geholfen
ja wie gesagt meine schwester hat zwei
kinder
und ich habe ihr manchmal mit den babys
geholfen
was würden sie tun wenn ein kind fieber
hat
ich würde sofort zum arzt gehen und die
eltern informieren
ich bin sehr vorsichtig wenn kinder
zeichen von fieber haben
ich würde sofort zum arzt gehen und die
eltern informieren
ich bin sehr vorsichtig wenn kinder
zeichen von fieber haben
was halten sie von disziplin
ich mag disziplin bin aber nicht streng
ich denke die routine hilft
diszipliniert zu sein
ich mag disziplin bin aber nicht streng
ich denke die routine hilft
diszipliniert zu sein
wenn man etwas immer wieder holt dann
wird man automatisch auch diszipliniert
zb mit dem zimmer aufräumen
wenn man etwas immer wieder holt dann
wird man automatisch auch diszipliniert
zum beispiel mit dem zimmer aufräumen
haben sie noch fragen an uns
ja wie ist man als ob er versichert wird
die kranken und unfallversicherung von
der gastfamilie bezahlt
ja wie ist man als ob er versichert wird
die kranken und unfallversicherung von
der gastfamilie bezahlt
ja die gastfamilie muss für sie eine
kranken- und unfallversicherung
abschließen
ja die gastfamilie muss für sie eine
kranken- und unfallversicherung
abschließen
habe ich als ob er auch mal ferien
je nachdem wie lange sie bleiben pro
jahr stehen ihnen vier wochen ferien zu
ich würde auch gerne die landessprache
lernen wie oft und wie lange kann ich
einen sprachkurs besuchen
ich würde auch gerne die landessprache
lernen wie oft und wie lange kann ich
einen sprachkurs besuchen
das müssen sie mit der gastfamilie
vereinbaren
vielen dank ich habe keine fragen mehr
ok - a wir beenden hier das
vorstellungsgespräch
ich danke ihnen für ihre zeit
ok - a wir beenden hier das
vorstellungsgespräch
ich danke ihnen für ihre zeit
wir rufen sie morgen an und geben ihn
bescheid abwehr sie als ob er vermitteln
werden
wir rufen sie morgen an und geben ihn
bescheid ob wir sie als ob er vermitteln
werden
ich danke ihnen
die einladung und das nette gespräch ich
freue mich auf ihren anruf
ich danke ihnen für die einladung und
das nette gespräch
ich freue mich auf ihren anruf
hallo
guten morgen frau gomez hier spricht
frau serrano von der op agentur
wir hatten gestern ein
vorstellungsgespräch
guten morgen frau gomez hier spricht
frau serrano von der pr agentur
wir hatten gestern ein
vorstellungsgespräch
guten morgen frau serrano ich freue mich
von ihnen zu hören
ich hoffe sie haben gute neuigkeiten
guten morgen frau serrano ich freue mich
von ihnen zu hören
ich hoffe sie haben gute neuigkeiten
ja das habe ich sie dürfen schon mal
ihre koffer packen
denn sie wurden ausgewählt um mit uns
zusammenzuarbeiten
ja das habe ich sie dürfen schon mal
ihre koffer packen
denn sie wurden ausgewählt um mit uns
zusammenzuarbeiten
wirklich wow das ist wunderbar
gratuliere wir haben schon ein paar
familien in der schweiz gefunden
in ein paar tagen haben wir alles für
sie organisiert
die schweiz cool ich freue mich sehr
vielen dank dass sie mir diese chance
geben
ich bin sehr glücklich
die schweiz cool ich freue mich sehr
vielen dank dass sie mir diese chance
geben
ich bin sehr glücklich möchtest du noch
weitere videos sehen dann abonniere
unseren kanal jeden sonntag ein neues
video
möchtest du noch weitere videos sehen
dann abonniere unseren kanal jeden
sonntag ein neues video